I decided to direct one of our shorts
not knowing which one I was going to
direct and I was I was looking at three
or four different scripts and they're
all vying to get made and I'm working on
it but I couldn't get there creatively
and the writer and my executive producer
Brad winter man was feeling my
frustration and they went out and they
were brainstorming they came back with a
one-line pitch to me Bonnie and Clyde
side coupled down and had on their luck
you know find one of the alien weapons
the whole I guess interesting element in
terms of like some kind of real story
development coming out of this is that
some human fortunately being me in this
case Bennie in this case has figured out
how to get these guns to work they're
not supposed to work unless the portals
open and they're gold there you know and
meanwhile somebody figured it out that's
a big piece of Intel for shield yeah and
so while they were supposed to kill us
because he's like this fancy Brainiac
they decide
yeah and I said I love that and I loved
it for many reasons I love that we had a
strong female character I love that
agent Sitwell who's been living in the
shadows of Agent Coulson gets to prove
himself and most importantly I like that
to people outside the Marvel Cinematic
Universe are now thrown into it
headfirst so I said right it literally
three hours later he comes back with a
screenplay listen and you know following
Coulson for all those years what would
Coulson do that was in his mind you know
these people are so creative and
inventive and the resolute in their in
their plant I'm gonna bring him in to
shield you know I'm not only am I not
going to neutralize them I'm gonna hire
them I mean that was really the reason
why I wanted to do it I want to play
with alien guns and blow up like massive
sets and so they had it all rigged to
really blow up to really blow without
CGI oh yeah actually that was a hole in
the wall it was it really was and they
are you know the guys who work at Marvel
are like 14 year olds in their
excitement about like explodes and stuff
like that and so they had it all set up
with you know cannons with debris and
then I just had to they counted down and
I had to sort of do that and it
miraculously worked on the first take
but the timing looks right you
yeah you know it's it we want to keep
tits the cold Marvel one-shot for a
reason in the comics the one shot is is
a self-contained book comic book just
for that one one issue the same thing
with the shorts and we we can do a
couple of things with them we can
highlight a character put a spotlight on
them we can show more interconnectivity
and also we can have what we did here is
it's more companion piece and what if
you know what a what-if situation so you
know I think it's a basic story though
good versus evil and what it has though
it has a lot of heart a lot of humor and
I think it's it's not there's not a
target audience of say young people or
old people it's all audiences so you put
those ingredients together and you have
a very successful film but I think
people are people are craving these type
of stories where where you is a clear
delineation between good and evil and
many heroes maybe are not are not a
flawed and they're not perfect and
they're interesting even without their
superpowers so there's a they're very
relatable and I think we can expect Iron
Man 3 which we're currently filming we
can expect Thor 2 which will have a
title other than Thor 2 we will can
expect Captain America to and I would
sure you'll see another Avengers now we
have tonight in Hall H we might make an
announcement of a couple of other a
couple of other titles but I have to
reserve that for whole age